>> THE SENATE HAS PIVOTED FROM
ONE OF THE MOST CONTENTIOUS,
PARTISAN PERIODS IN THE NATION’S
HISTORY TO PASSING THIS RESCUE
PACKAGE 100 TO 0.
BRIAN: HOURS AGO THE SENATE
PASSED A 2.2 TRILLION-DOLLAR
STIMULUS RELIEF BILL FOR
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS IMPACTED
BY THE CORONAVIRUS.
NO ONE HAS NOT BEEN IMPACTED.
THAT RELIEF PACKAGE NOW HEADS TO
THE HOUSE.
WHAT CAN WE EXPECT?
NO BETTER PERSON TO ASK THAN
MINORITY LEADER KEVIN MCCARTHY
WHO JOINS US NOW.
KEVIN, THE BALL IS YOURS, 96-0
FROM THE SENATE.
WHERE DOES THE HOUSE STAND ON
THIS?
>> I BELIEVE THE HOUSE WILL PASS
THIS BILL.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE ABLE
TO READ IT.
THE FINAL TEXT DID NOT COME OUT
UNTIL LAST NIGHT.
REMEMBER THE SIZE AND THE SCOPE
OF HOW MUCH MONEY THIS IS.
SO WE WILL TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO READ THROUGH IT TODAY.
WE WILL VOTE ON FRIDAY, TOMORROW
IN THE MORNING.
BUT THE FLOOR WILL LOOK
DIFFERENT.
REMEMBER WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF MEMBERS WHO
HAVE THE VIRUS ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE.
>> WE HAVE A NUMBER OF MEMBERS
WHO ARE QUARANTINED.
WE HAVE CHALLENGES FOR FLYING
HERE BECAUSE SOME FLIGHTS ARE
BEING CANCELLED.
SO YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE THE FULL
BODY.
BUT YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU
HAVE THE DEBATE AND THOSE
CONSTITUENTS HAVE THEIR VOICES.
IT WILL PASS, BUT THIS TIME NOT
WITH THE UNANIMOUS CONSENT WITH
NO DEBATE.
WE WILL HAVE A DEBATE AND THEN
WE WILL HAVE A VOICE VOTE TO
BRING IT UP AND MOVE IT TO THE
PRESIDENT’S DESK.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE HAVE WASTED
THIS ENTIRE WEEK BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS WANTED TO PUT IN THEIR
ELECTION LAW CHANGES, BAIL OUT
PENSIONS, PUT THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
WE WERE ABLE TO KEEP THAT OUT.
THEY DID PUT SOME MORE FUNDING
FOR THINGS THAT DON’T DEAL WITH
CORONAVIRUS, BUT WE WILL STILL
GET THIS PACKAGE THAT IS NEEDED
FOR THE HOSPITALS.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
>> FOR THE SMALL BUSINESSES TO
KEEP PEOPLE EMPLOYED.
THAT’S THE KEY PART HERE.
AND EVERY DAY MATTERS.
SO WE WANT TO GET THIS DONE
QUICKLY.
BRIAN: I LOVE THE FACT THERE IS
INCENTIVE.
THESE ARE LOANS AND GRANTS.
UNLESS YOU DO NOT EFFORT TO KEEP
90% OF YOUR EMPLOYEES THEN THEY
BECOME LOANS.
YOU HAVE GOT TO PAY THEM BACK.
AN INCENTIVE TO KEEP PEOPLE ON
THE JOB.
I LOVE THAT WHEN YOU ARE COMING
IN PEOPLE MIGHT BE THINKING TO
THEMSELVES OKAY THAT’S A
REPUBLICAN COMING IN CRITICIZING
A DEMOCRAT.
YOU ARE ACTUALLY BEING
100 PERCENT ACCURATE WITH NO
POLITICAL AGENDA.
NANCY PELOSI CAME IN DEMANDING
MANDATORY EARLY VOTING.
BALLOT HARVESTING.
PROVISIONS ON E.P.A. STANDARDS
OVER THE NEXT 20 YEARS FOR
AIRPLANES.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD FINANCING AND
SHE DID GET SOME STUFF BUT NOT
ALL THE STUFF.
WHAT DID THAT DO TO THE MONEY
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
WAITING FOR?
>> WELL, IT’S VERY FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE IF YOU ARE A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER.
THAT’S WHAT I WAS.
YOU ARE SITTING AROUND A KITCHEN
TABLE RIGHT NOW TRYING TO MAKE A
DECISION DO YOU LAY PEOPLE OFF
OR NOT.
WHAT THIS IS HELP ON THE WAY.
WHEN THIS PASSES, YOU CANNOT
ONLY JUST GET A LOAN BUT IF YOU
KEEP PAYING YOUR EMPLOYEES AND
PAYING YOUR RENT, THAT PORTION
OF IT IS FORGIVEN.
YOU DON’T PAY IT BACK.
IT’S THE INCENTIVE TO KEEP
AMERICA WORKING BECAUSE SOME
MILLIONS OF US WORK IN A SMALL
BUSINESS AND LARGER BUSINESS
MEANING YOU HAVE MORE THAN 500
EMPLOYEES WE ARE GOING TO
PROVIDE YOU THE LOAN GUARANTEE
BUT WE ALSO HAVE A TAX INCENTIVE
IN THERE WHERE WE COULD PAY UP
FOR 50% OF EMPLOYEES FOR TWO
MONTHS.
WE WANT TO KEEP AMERICA WORKING.
THAT MAKES US STRONGER BUT WE
ALSO DEAL WITH UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE.
THE ONE THING ABOUT NANCY PELOSI
THERE SHE DIDN’T GET THAT MONEY
IN THE BILL.
SHE PLUCKED UP MORE THINGS THAT
DIDN’T DEAL WITH THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THAT’S THE PAIN WE HAD TO PUT UP
FOR THREE DAYS OF NOT GETTING
THIS BILL MOVED.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
SHE DID GET $25 MILLION FOR THE
KENNEDY CENTER.
THINK ABOUT HOW THAT WOULD HAVE
BENEFITED HOSPITALS.
ALSO, SMALL BUSINESSES NOW HAVE
TO STAY OUT OF UNION
ORGANIZATION EFFORTS.
SO SHE GOT THAT WHAT DOES THAT
HAVE TO DO WITH ANYTHING TO DO
WITH THIS PACKAGE?
REAL QUICK, CONGRESSMAN, THEY
ARE SAYING THEY ARE GOING BACK
FOR A FOURTH AND FIFTH.
SENATOR BLUMENTHAL SAYS WHAT WE
DIDN’T GET HERE WE WILL GET ON
THE FOURTH AND FIFTH ROUNDS.
ARE WE EXPECTING TWO MORE ROUNDS
OF TRILLION-DOLLAR RESCUE
PACKAGES?
>> I WOULD TAKE A DEEP BREATH.
WE HAVE NOW JUST PASSED.
THIS WOULD BE THE THIRD BILL.
LET’S LET THIS WORK.
LET’S LET THIS WORK INSIDE
AMERICA.
BECAUSE I KNOW THE INGENUITY,
THE INTENSITY AND THE
INSPIRATION WE CAN OVERCOME.
THIS WE HAVE NOW GIVEN THE
RESOURCES TO MAKE AND SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
WE DON’T NEED TO BE CRAFTING
ANOTHER BILL RIGHT NOW.
LET’S LET THESE $2 TRILLION GO
TO WORK FOR US, PLUS THE
8 BILLION AHEAD OF TIME AND THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WE JUST
PASSED ON THE SECOND BILL.
BRIAN: WE JUST HAVE TO FIND A
WAY TO GET SECURE REMOTE VOTING
FOR SENATOR THUNE AND SENATOR
RAND PAUL NOT TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE BIG PICTURE
IN THE YEAR 2020, I THINK WE CAN
HANDLE THAT.
BUT FOR NOW, LET’S GET THROUGH
THIS WEEK.
AND WE WILL HOPEFULLY GET A
PASSAGE ON FRIDAY.
LEADER MCCARTHY, THANKS FOR
TELLING US THE LATEST NEWS.
APPRECIATE IT?